respirer un peu l'air frais de la mer et
se détendre sur la plage un geste simple
répit est essentielle après presque
trois mois d'hyères une activité
pourtant illégament à odessa le bord de
mer est une zone interdite car la ville
portuaire vie depuis février dans la
crainte d'un débarquement russe et s'est
transformé en forteresse même les
statues et monuments ils sont protégés
le quartier où habite victoria les souks
et sa fille nicole est l'un des plus
beaux et plus paisible de dessin mais il
est aujourd'hui méconnaissable
c'était irréel au début dit elle mais
après trois mois on s'y fait c'est
devenu notre nouvelle réalité
victoria s'est habitué aussi aux
pénuries de carburant et aux produits
manquants à l'épicerie mais la peur de
la guerre elle n'est pas passée
quand on voit ce qui s'est produit à
marioupol et ailleurs c'est très
difficile dit-elle on espère vraiment
rester en paix parce que c'est une très
belle ville
connue comme la perle de la mer noire
odessa et fier de son riche patrimoine
architectural et culturel
fier de son identité unique et si ses
habitants ont réussi en 2014 a résisté à
l'annexion et à la fièvre séparatiste
ils sont bien conscients que leur ville
fait maintenant face à l'une des menaces
les plus graves de son histoire
c'est la raison pour laquelle alexander
steen its qui a décidé de prendre les
armes de se porter volontaire pour
défendre sa ville depuis ils montent la
garde tous les jours sur ce point de
contrôle à deux pas de l'opéra un
changement de vie qui layton lui-même
des faux derche au
début de la guerre dit il je ne serai
jamais vu faire ce que je fais
actuellement
c'est qu'alexander n'est pas un
va-t-en-guerre loin s'en faut
universitaire citoyen du monde il se
décrit comme un pacifiste
et non
il n'y a pas de justification pour la
guerre peu importe laquelle dit-il mais
surtout celle ci
alexander n'est pas un militaire de
carrière ni même un conscrit c'est donc
de son plein gré qu'il enfile son
uniforme chaque jour et retourne à son
poste de garde après son café du matin
une routine est immuable depuis bientôt
trois mois
pour lui il s'agit de défendre ses
concitoyens une identité mais aussi un
idéal car pour alexander l'ukraine est
un exemple d'ouverture et de tolérance
je peux par les ukrainiens mais ma
langue maternelle est le russe dit il et
jamais je me suis sentie aux primaires
d'ukraine quand je parle le russe finans
alors ils interpellent les soldats
russes ennemis autrefois peuples frères
à ce qui sauf couach posez-vous
simplement cette question demande t-il
pour quelle cause vous regrettez vous
vous voyez farine fort parce que pour
alexander comme pour tous les habitants
de l'esa la réponse est très claire et
elle vaut tous les sacrifices
ici l'enfant ce mélange de radio-canada
au dessin